about the fact that someone went out of
their way and they wanted to do a
wonderful gesture for you that's the
point
and to sit here and demand an eight
carat ring
so that someone next door can see you
across the road well one year
clearly you've got insecurities because
you feel like that's what's going to add
value to you because it's not i'm
interested because it's quite
interesting that that upsets you um
because that's why i asked you well i'm
glad you clarified because at the
beginning you said you feel sorry for
her then you said you felt sorry for men
because
after that
i feel sorry for men because i mean
right
remember i said before we even watched i
knew what the woman looked like
and i think we can all
categorically agree without being harsh
that is a bang average looking lady
so that's the problem
your bang average looking lady would i
want this i want this i want this i want
this
and i think she listed one thing that
she offers she made 30 grand over the
weekend you told her
men don't care about money she then went
on to say
but it's what i care about but it's what
she has nothing to all she has a list of
requirements and she can't even offer
the first thing that men appreciate
which is what she looks like
which to me i know beauty is an alba
holder but that's a bang average looking
lady i don't know what you think you can
be honest
she was a very incredibly pretty lady
at least it had some sort of substance
and he said some sort of i mean level
where you could say all right cool she's
she
she's in the top ten percent of ladies
in the world she's asking for this crap
but at least off the bat she's pretty
but to give all of those requirements
and to be
oh god seriously i think the fact that
you know she felt like she could say
that and like felt like she had ground
to stand on is crazy like the fact that
you know you can um
she felt she feels like she's like
she can't expect that
and you know she was saying stuff like
um
oh yeah um
you get like the minimum expectation i
think it was something along those lines
right
no you get to have cats and probably die
alone and i have no like ill intent
towards this woman but seriously if
realistically if you are acting like
that anyone who's got that money is not
going to spend that money in that way
because it's it's dumb
it doesn't make sense and the fact that
she felt comfortable to say that in
public is just like
what is it contour you know what i mean
what is going on because that is the
illusion a lot more common than you
think as well by the way that that might
seem extreme
but it's actually not a lot of women
think
that's not what they desire i deserve
this by existing it's like how common
would you say that is um i think more in
america that's common in the uk
they think it's more common in america
yeah yeah okay
um
yeah
i won't say it's uncommon here though i
wouldn't say
i think they vocalize it more in america
yeah they definitely localize it more i
appreciate this in a way because at
least they're honest about it but yeah
in the uk that's honesty or
delusion delusion a mixture of both to
be honest
i think she's delusionally she's being
honest about how deluded she is yeah
yeah exactly
oh i see it anyway yeah because it lets
the men know who to avoid
exactly what if what if a woman comes to
you this for everybody what if a woman
comes to you and says that and you tell
her you're delusional and she's like
well i don't want to lower my standards
to
be able to get some random guy i'm going
gonna keep my standards like this what
would you guys say to her um i'd i'm
very much i say i was i don't really uh
cut out you know the the rough parts i
just kinda i don't be around the bush
i'm just direct to it i just tell her
straight up like
if you're expecting this then you're not
gonna get far with what you want
and you need to reevaluate and reassess
everything if you think
to this extreme
and also like
see
the example i gave earlier like the
single mother
obviously i'm not going to be like too
harsh because she's got at the end of
the day she's got a kid to look after
but
like you got to tell them like you can't
you need to humble yourself you know you
can't you can't go around expecting and
like expecting all this while like
you're burdening the man well it's on
the
other side of the coin well it's kind of
like if you're a used car and you're
asking new prices you can say that like
no one you know the
the only buyers that are going to come
are the ones that can afford you but if
no buyers come then whatever does that
leave you
should be on discount on i don't
understand why it's such a bad thing to
be on sale i'm on sale from 22.
[Laughter]
[Music]
yo yo yo me and jess are on a
two-for-one special sister sister-wise
[Laughter]
i had to watch that again but anyway but
uh
yeah okay she's to blame because she's
she's allowing herself to you know
run away with all these fantastical
ideas but also the dating coach
i think the daisy coach is taking her
for a ride and it's just like i'm gonna
just leave you to it and get the money
and then now she's fending for if the
day and coach actually said i want you
to actually meet this man who is willing
to give 200k whatever then that's
something but she i think she's
definitely been played no i i looked up
the dating coach
she was hotter
how do girls get better results
surprising
and i'm just like and it's so sad
because she she's the the dating coach
is making her believe yeah you can get
whatever what i've got that's what girls
will say like
okay for example sierra right in a way
she she raised her price a bit
and she she ended up with like i'd say
russell's a better husband than future
but that that works if you're
hot i mean maybe you could have food to
do that yeah that's what i'm saying like
i'm not saying i don't think it works
the majority of the time everyone looks
at russell as a simp but the girls that
it works out for you by the way aren't
what i think yeah yeah but
the girls that it works out for are
extremely hot that's not going to look
work for the average girl and so they'll
look at girls that do that that are
hotter than them and think oh if i do
that then i could but it's like nah well
i'll show you it ain't you i also think
that um
that uh you know women giving women
advice a lot of the time tends to be um
telling them what they want to hear
rather than what they need to hear i uh
i honestly feel like that's the way
things are going whether it's like girl
you were 10. you know like that's
that's most of the case never true right
um tens are perfect and i happen to
believe that perfect never exists so um
you there's always a way to better
yourself so
you
know um
you know saying that like they can they
can get like the
these high-end men it's just it's the
same thing it's just telling them what
they want to hear because they want not
in a man so
the advice is oh yeah um
you're writing one in that you deserve
that be all that you know [ __ ] when
at the end of the day the need to hear
is
you need a reality check and you need to
sort your head out because it's like
do you think that's all women like what
we saw in the video or do you think it's
a certain type of ethnicity or
demographic of women this is a question
for everybody i mean i could keep it 100
and say that's a more of a problem in
the black community i think in my
opinion i can't
i'm not gonna hide
his way